if you could put a top three reasons why
a woman is looking to divorce her man or
break up with her man in your opinion
what would it be meaning it could be
money it could be looks it could be not
communicating it could be infidelity
based on your experience what are the
top three reasons you're seeing women
just trying to break up with their men
or divorce their men
I think uh I'll tell you what I
personally think is happening in the
marriages and then I'll tell you the top
three things I would say probably
working too much that the man is working
too much yeah I think a lot of women get
you know bitter about that if they're
having to take on too much you know a
role elsewhere because a lot of women
work now too right so it's it's
different it's not like you can't really
complain when you're at home taking care
of the kids and being a housewife like
that's your role but when you're also
working and doing that and it's not a
meet in the middle in between there then
you know obviously so it's the man
working too much and her working too
much yeah I would say I've heard
complaints you know like or maybe
they're always on business or they
travel or I mean obviously I think
there's a distrust there could be you
know something there where maybe they
have a very active lifestyle outside of
the marriage in which maybe they don't
trust their friends or who they're
around
um those are some common reasons that's
number two distrust yeah distrust
um and then I think generally that I
personally think not enough marriages do
not really prioritize sex like I don't
think people understand how incredibly
important that is and a lot of women is
like you know get bitter and want to
withhold and I'm not yeah and I think
that is incredibly toxic not only for
the marriage not just for him but for
the woman herself because I think that's
why a lot of marriages I am almost
shocked that these women say they won't
have sex for months with their husband
I'm like holy cow well it's no wonder
your marriages or is she coaching that's
unacceptable I really do believe that
it's more common than you know okay my
husband hears it you know would hear it
at work other guys like you know he he
was always kind of the guy in the corner
like they don't have like I can always
say there's never been a day in my
marriage that I did not have sex with my
husband like a day literally unless I
was out gone away from him Steve shout
out to you brother we just but it's so
important and I think that uh that is
vastly and you're aware of that as a
wife to say all right it is my
responsibility to make sure my man is
fulfilled yes and I think women also
give up
um they don't try tries hard they think
they don't have to continue to be sexy a
lot of women and I've been there I've
gone through phases you know where I
didn't feel sexy I had two kids back to
back basically at one point and you know
I didn't feel great I was overweight and
I still made time for that though but a
lot of women immerse themselves in that
lifestyle and then of just taking care
of the kids and just chop chop chop and
they totally forget to to really like
marinate and take care of their marriage
so working too much so basically not
paying attention developing a distrust
and then thirdly sex so this is coming
from a woman who's been married 22 years
yeah so Nat yes you've never been
married yes you have a lot of suitors
yes you're a little hottie hotty toddy
out there you're out there okay why do
you think like speaking from a a young
woman's perspective I'm not even talking
about marriage
but you've had boyfriends a lot of your
girlfriends your sisters they've had
boyfriends what are the top three
reasons they break up with their men
um
in the dating
um
I don't find like money to be too much
in dating now when you're married I know
money is definitely one
um attention is another one um and I
mean in like all areas on the bedroom
like going on dates like attention in
all aspects
um so number one attention yeah uh yes
pay attention to me I want some quality
time yeah absolutely something about
that meat right there
which is what I was referring to when I
was talking about like working too much
like they're not getting the attention
yeah I'm gonna come back I gotta go back
to a point you guys right after this 100
percent so number one attention
attention
um obviously if you're married um no no
no not married you're not you're just
dating yeah I I'm having people speak
from experiences so for dating um
attention
um what else is uh lack of clarity of
the relationship so like you're just
dating a date and like you're like just
netflixing and chilling you're like um
this is going nowhere also lack of
clarity so to be clear that usually
happens right around the three month
Mark you'll get to so where's this going
and the guy who's open like after like
the first month the first month you
should kind of get a feel of like where
is this going like are we consistently
going the same places like are they
adventurous do I like this so don't
waste your time okay jump in you should
know
um and then the last one the last one I
would say
um
um I would say maybe uh
just the interest goes away maybe just
like a lot of option other options
um and and that can be a really big
distraction the jungle out there baby so
if you like that clip click right here
to watch another or if you want to watch
the entire saucecast click right here
[Music]